[Music]
i feel like i've known you
a long time it's been a long time how
many uh do
we meet
years ago on the old one of the old
shows i did your show that shall not be
named on
nbc oh the late night show yes that late
night talk show that you did you can
name that show i'm proud of that show um
and uh i that was seven years ago and it
was my very first talk show and it was
it was amazing because i was so um talk
shows are weird just for people like
it's a very strange and weird format to
get used to and i was completely green i
had just done like
10 episodes of the office and they're
like you're going to do conan o'brien
and i was so you were just totally my
idol and i was so beside myself and it
was crazy it was in new york city and
that's a crazy theater and you come out
and like the band is so loud and the
lights are swirling and the cameras are
moving the audience is like
and i'll never forget this i i came and
i sat down and you did this thing it's
like i was looking around like ah
i i didn't know where to look and you
were like you did this thing you
literally did
this thing
as you sat down you know you remember
that i don't remember i don't do that
with other people but maybe i saw that
you were kind of i think you did you'd
like so i guided you into these diapers
like like
those beautiful blue pools of love yeah
um
[Laughter]
and uh no it was it really saved me do
you do that i don't i don't do that to
anybody it was like a jedi mind trick
yeah i think i probably saw you know
okay he's wandering he's confused let's
try it again i tried to i tried to lure
you in like
let's reenact it
that's exactly how it went yeah exactly
we recreated
[Music]
now i don't i didn't do that i'm holding
the moon oh you're holding the moon
let me help you oh uh uh it's tricky um
you are so popular now hugely you are
you're very yeah
i'm enormous and you've uh you've kept
it all in perspective yeah
i'm amazing yeah yeah i hold the moon up
next question um
fans of yours get tattoos of of dwight
on their body do they not this is true
this is a recent phenomenon in the last
couple years every once in a while like
on twitter or facebook they'll i'll see
these photos that get sent in
and uh there are quite a lot of people
out there sporting dwight tattoos and
it's how do you feel about that are you
okay with that it's very flattering and
um it's it's it it's very very kind but
i really i really worry for them and not
not for like they're mentally but just
more like like what's gonna happen in
like the year 2043 yeah you know when
they're old you know and they've got
walkers or something like that and they
have to explain to their grandchildren
like well there was this thing called
television and
there were these 22-minute shows that
had these commercial breaks in between
and on it was this very bizarre
character with an enormous head played
by rayne wilson named dwight and i loved
this character so i got it tattooed on
my calf
on the entirety of my calf it's crazy
well we have uh these are real these are
off the internet
these are absolutely real that's really
keep going
yeah
i don't know
oh my god oh okay that's a thigh i like
that's
sort of a saucy i'm next to a zombie
yeah there you are you've got some
company there and there's another one
coming soon about oh wow
assistant regional manager and that's
going right up to the buttock there that
is incredible beautiful woman's thigh
you can tell right there and i just
wonder
like does you know if she's
making
lovely love with her man friend and like
he's mounting her
and
how often how often do you think about
this
um but he's looking down he's seeing my
face you know
it's so weird and i wonder if he could
get
like
if he if he would get like an angela
tattoo my love interest from the office
tattooed on his thigh and then they
would merge
what are you talking about
you're dangerously ill
i think about it but i think about the
same things we have uh people you have
we have people send in i think we have a
few examples there's one i actually kind
of like
where i'm wearing a space collar and
then this one i wasn't so crazy about oh
no that looks like i'm entering
re-entering orbit and getting burned up
i think
you look like the joker unintentionally
yeah and you know what andy has that one
that's andy's
andy